a doctored video of Speaker Nancy Pelosi
has been viewed millions of times on
social media it's being flagged this
morning because of concerns that it
could influence political perception the
Washington Post analyzed a video of
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi speaking on
Wednesday on the left is a version that
the post says was edited and slowed down
the version on the right is untouched
Pelosi appears to be slurring her speech
200 years ago
Thomas Jefferson tasked his Secretary of
the Treasury the other almost in right
there to to develop a infrastructure
initiative for American 200 years ago
Thomas Jefferson tasked his secretary of
the Treasury the other almost an eye
right there to to develop a
infrastructure initiative for America
obviously that's the slowed down version
you heard last there yesterday President
Trump tweeted a different edited video
that aired on the Fox Business Network
in it Pelosi appears to stammer through
a news conference Fox Business says in a
statement it did not slow the clip down
Cantonese so important to call that out
because if you're only getting your news
from one place that's where I think
you've got to look at a variety of
sources if you only get it from one
place you get a totally skewed view of
what has happened and it's amazing what
a difference that a little bit of
slowing down video and how easy it is to
edit in doctor video you have to be if
you see with your eyes and hear with
your ears you can believe it yeah but
not anymore I'm not so sure